hey Lou you've got some new computers -
welcome to camp kikiwaka these newcomers
have got some pretty big shoes to fill
but we know you'll show them the ropes
we heard that you're the funniest and
nicest counselor in this neck of the
woods so do you mind if we tag along
with you we can't wait to hear about all
your camp stories from bunked and bring
your friends - here are 10
behind-the-scenes secrets from Disney
Channel's bunk'd watch until the end to
find out what Peyton lists biggest
complaints about the show is friends in
real life in the behind the scenes
interview with young Hollywood the cast
shared that they loved hanging out
together all the time they practically
spent every waking moment together after
they wrapped the production for the day
they typically go to the movies grab
some dinner or just hang out together
from now on we will all be enjoying meat
free meals car and share that if you
hang out on set and still want to get
together away from the set as well it's
a clear sign of a special bond between
cast mates Hades favorite episode when
Peyton lists was still on the show she
gave a behind-the-scenes tour of the set
and the camp cabins for Disney style on
the tour she spilled the tea on her
favorite episode ever she shared that
the first episode was pretty fun because
they had a giant mud pit on the front
lawn fun fact that mud was actually
chocolate pie filling Peyton said that
she couldn't eat it though it had been
sitting out in the Sun all day
yeah that's not very appetizing the
script changes everyday in a
behind-the-scenes video with Skye
Jackson she shared an alarming facts
about the production of the show she
says that the scripts they wind up
shooting are not the same as the scripts
they receive at the very beginning of
the episodes we were totally surprised
to find out that the script changes
every day can you imagine having to
memorize new lines every time you get on
set Skye said that the cast has to stay
sharp because filming the show can get
pretty unpredictable Karan Brar favorite
treat you might think that since Karan
Brar starred in a hit Disney TV show
that he would have a sophisticated
palate something like creme brulee would
be the dessert he prefers when he
goes to his dressing room however young
Hollywood found out what his favorite
treat was and surprised him with it
during his interview can you guess what
it is if you guess JoJo's you're correct
the simple things in life can be so good
they visit other show sets the Disney
lot is buzzing with many different shows
all across the studio you could wonder
from one set to the next if you have
enough time and nowhere to go and that's
exactly what the cast of bunk does
according to sky Jackson it was pretty
common for her and her cast mates to go
and visit Cameron Boyce on gamers guide
they would also stop by and say hi to
dove Cameron on the set of Liv and
Maddie memorizing lines was a breeze for
this star while the script changed every
day during the rehearsal process there
was one actor on the show who had no
problem memorizing her lines Skye
Jackson said that memorizing lines was
super easy for her so how did she
memorize all of those constantly
changing lines she doesn't really know
memorizing lines just comes really easy
to her she would rehearse from Monday
through Wednesday and by Friday she had
them all down and was ready to go that's
impressive Skye nicknames Skye Jackson
revealed that the members of the cast
had nicknames for each other for some
undisclosed reason she gave Kevin the
nickname Gerald what does that even mean
I don't know she said it was from an
inside joke soon after she started
calling him Gerald everyone joined in
she thought it was his middle name but
she was not 100% sure on that on the
bunk to set Skye was known as Skye Dax
it sounds like they just shortened her
last name to come up with that one it's
much less creative than Gerald
role-models
Kevin Quinn was known for his gorgeous
singing voice as well as his acting jobs
that he has looked to a certain person
for inspiration ever since he started
singing and acting in the first place as
it turns out kevin is a major fanboy for
a certain popstar can you name who it is
we'll give you a hint he can be a total
troll but in the cutest way possible
we're talking about Justin Timberlake
Kevin loves the way Justin balances his
acting and music career big bros if
you're thinking that some of the cast
our besties in real life you're totally
right during an interview with pop mania
sky Jackson share that she spends the
most time with Karen and Kevin behind
the scenes she thinks of them as her big
brothers they love to have lunch
together in their dressing rooms and
even play some basketball whenever they
have time they get along great
if you think about it they are the
perfect fit for each other and since
they all see each other as family it
makes sense that Skye gains a couple of
big brothers while filming for the show
Peyton's biggest complaint in her behind
the scenes interviews with a Disney
style
Peyton showed us her favorite place on
the whole set while she was on the show
she loved the fire pit it was her
favorite because it was where they all
gathered around sang songs and made
s'mores but she had one big complaint
she had to get off her chest the cast
never got to actually eat those s'mores
and she said that was a major bummer
who's your favorite character from
bunk'd tell us in the comments and be
sure to subscribe to the things so you
never miss another video and while
you're at it go ahead and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]